okay Mike still on all right hi I'm Greg
hey guys I'm Tara hey guys I'm Greg
introduce this is uh Tara Eriksen yeah
Eric Eric sim so of course I remember I
forget the last name by the way
Tara Eric sent Sarah Erickson I saw her
Instagram and then I saw her YouTube
channel and then I watched a few of her
sketches and I was like this woman's
really funny
she's really funny he was like move on
now she's here because I'm here
that's how collabs worked that's how
collabs work contact people go check out
her channel you just get the URL for
interpreters yeah yeah it's just
youtube.com yes yes yes I've got time
that flash Tara Erickson or just search
hashtags this idiot because that's what
I go by
maybe we'll Caroline beg to come on the
chat I did I was actually desperate for
for this attention right now
so it's Easter guys yeah we are spending
our Easter together making creative
content for you yeah exactly because it
may care more about you than personal
and our like who needs that right now
what other than Easter message from Sean
Spicer well and I'll sketch I forgot a
screenshot everyone who requested this
because I get anxious when new guest is
by to make sure we just hurry up when I
feel like we're slowing down like I'm
feeling right now just watching this
video let's just watch the video Oh Jay
I'm anxious Tara reaches
but why have push me I'm sweating my
Easter eggs often infants everybody shut
up so I can apologize yes y'all got your
wrist this way Jinja huh spicy finally
made a mistake president Ron recently
mom Syria hmm while eating the most
beautiful piece of chocolate cake so now
in defending the president's decision I
said that unless Syrian leader of the
leader of I got a bazooka Felicia Rashad
pepper never used chemical weapons and
everybody free okay they were all like
ooh what about the whole cost centers oh
yeah I know they're not really called
Holocaust centers oh I know that I'm
aware I clearly missed this any
concentration club picture and didn't
solely focus on every little floor and
why I say last night
here let y'all see you know I am
sensitive to the fact that they were
sent there on trains but hey at least
they didn't have to fly United am i
right oh oh now I am particularly sorry
this happened the same week as Passover
or a que a Jewish Easter so in the
spirit of cultural unity I thought I
could shed some light up to all the boys
out there on the door sacred holiday
Passover I'll bring out my baby doll
Oh the most effective Sean Spicer
here we go here's Sarah okay
Sarah is a bad bad hombre and he's doing
some really bad stuff to the Jews oh my
god I mean not even Hitler me once shame
on me for me twice shame on you you guys
need to start making pyramids and stuff
and then the Jew did you see guys pass
over oh you guys literally quote above
the Pharaoh kind of like Crouching Tiger
yeah see a feral wouldn't want to be you
from then on pretty much smooth sailing
for the Jews huh
okay just to be super clear car and bad
guys go ranking is go right up at the
top Hitler
Oh coming in at number one then serious
borrow a shot tonight I'm going to go
pharaohs and then they get
chronologically juice take number four
wraps it up for me
happy Easter everybody well by the way
the presidents probably gonna bomb North
Korea tonight Oh God and deliver me
beige everybody just as much candy as
you want to just probably our last
Easter on earth so much that's crazy
as is insane to see just how I was
watching it I kind of like she was
improvising it a little bit I know right
she seems so natural and authentic I'm
like you made this a full character now
you're like a multi layers she's just
walking around the inspector oh yeah
it's not just an impersonation now or
you made a human being and yeah she is
my favorite part was here's the Pharaoh
and the Jews ha oh my god those are most
offensive Sean Spicer Lee why Sean
Spicer messes up the name all the time
he's been on Wolf Blitzer he did it
twice and then what Blitzer was like I
don't I can't even say it right now
because I did the same thing but he
calls it like bazooka but ball of shards
so follow sharkita has no idea it's so
embarrassing he's messed it up so many
times I'm like I'm glad they finally
yeah this SNL sketches though to me me
because I might when I get like the news
on what's going on politics i watch like
Seth Meyers and Stephen yeah bear and
knowing Trevor I don't really go to like
you know CNN right right watching like
the serious reports on it I need it to
be lightened up a little bit for how
crazy everything is in America and even
reference like the United Airline thing
which was so crazy crazy on top of it oh
god that's oh my god yeah like no no oh
my god I tweeted I was like see you
never united just never I can't no no I
I've been in that situation before you
have yeah really
yeah I've been taken off a plane before
why could you were intoxicated you're
being a jerk oh my gosh you were just
yelling out movie titles and they were
like everybody shut up oh my god back
yelling out movies that was part of it I
was really high I was smoking on the
plane okay
and they dragged me out and broke my
nose
they broke your nose I was so I was so
excited I could I can keep this going
really Colleen but it's kind of scary to
most points as part of the whole week
where I just get that go that's your a
really comfortable on it is my chair I
usually sit in yeah well yeah oh my god
armrest this is feels interesting yeah I
feel more like I don't feel like a king
do you not feel like yourself I feel
great
where's the Kandi's Easter Jinyoung can
be here for me Yeah right she pounded
jelly beans and I at the end after she
ran over the podium and I might I need I
want jelly beans that's right okay
Easter today do you uh how do you use a
cell for Easter I don't you don't I why
me you know you go out knowledge capital
you eat you eat chocolates and jelly
beans and you drink except I just
started a 10-day no drinking thing yes I
know I decided that today just let's not
talk about it or remind me I'm just
going to decide to drink a lot of Diet
Coke and get addicted to that and life
will be fine okay congratulations
that's the much healthier alternative
yeah it is so you didn't like egg hunt
growing up I loved the egg hunt oh my
gosh my mom was buying me a big basket
with a bunny in there with all the
candies and then you have to go
find all the eggs and they all had
chocolates and treats in them that was a
good time I would give money sometimes
you get half of money actual cash o5o
jazz it was the most awesome thing in
the world oh my gosh now you're bringing
back my memories me I believe they used
to leave actually change quarters yeah
exactly recorded in there yeah I know I
would do that we'd add it all up and you
put it in a little point yeah we're here
to kid you
yeah buddy when you were a kid yeah you
just needed one sleeve of them quarters
and you were like I'm going to the mall
and I was also grew up Catholic so I
would go to Sunday Mass okay oh yeah
really early Rauf like seven why do they
do that when why it's like just another
reason like it's torture it is what it
is the story I ain't going a mask that
early was torture medics and Ron and
then we get McDonald's breakfast oh that
makes it worth it I'll get up at 7:00
for McDonald's right now it's 21 oh yes
oh oh I would get the two sausage
McMuffin with egg and then two hash
browns that's legit I used to get that
do you guys remember wait wait breakfast
wait when I was younger
ya know when you were yellow I'll split
a sausage McMuffin that's it yeah we
didn't have much money when I got older
when you got older and you could afford
it you were like I'll take to everything
yeah when I got older I started doubling
up on that
no I got that it was like half a sausage
McMuffin half a hashmap
oh that's that no I'm not having that
poverty yeah I didn't have any money
growing up either but I did always get
my own but I'm an only child so I didn't
have to split it with anybody pancake
breakfast but they give you that weird
bacon which is not baking out things
bacon I don't know and then the eggs if
they're not a pancake they're not
pancaked but it's delicious though it's
the best thing that you'll ever have in
Ohio
breakfast system we need a high five in
the camera wasn't getting this thing
over here there you go yeah just talk
over yeah all right guys well we're
gonna wrap this video up we got more to
film well drive to the real rejects you
can
notification bell if you want to I love
seeing these YouTube things that
youtubers say Tara Ericsson follow her
on her YouTube channel so yeah really
funny sketches on their first when I saw
was your April when you and April Fool's
yeah yeah you and your boyfriend are
trying to come up with what's your
boyfriend's ooh yeah no no he's not my
body was on your actual boyfriend
erector and I met her and he's one of my
best friends and he Co writes some of
the sketches that we do okay yeah and it
was really fun good stuff the April
Fool's the satisfactory from
unsatisfactory go find me
I'm very pretty a character and
Instagram Twitter analyze but yeah all
of it it's all in the description box go
there oh and happy Easter to all you
[ __ ] yeah happy Easter you
[ __ ] yeah you pieces of [ __ ] yeah
bleep that out
[ __ ] i we don't know anything no all
right [ __ ] the restricted mode on
YouTube
mmm going out there to you guys I'm
[ __ ] Easter alright it this is the day
the Easter Bunny raised Jesus from the
dead
enjoy yourself Oh